let me start by addressing a few
misconceptions about body dance of which
we are a subsidiary
by dance is not owned or controlled by
the Chinese government
it's a private company sixty percent of
the company is owned by global
institutional investors 20 is owned by
the founder and 20 owned by employees
around the world
Biden says five board members three of
them are American
now Tick Tock itself is not available in
mainland China we're headquartered in
Los Angeles and in Singapore and we have
7 000 employees in the US today
still we have heard important concerns
about the potential for unwanted foreign
access to U.S data and potential
manipulation of The Tick Tock U.S
ecosystem
our approach has never been to dismiss
or trivialize any of these concerns we
have addressed them with real action
now that's what we've been doing for the
last two years building what amounts to
a firewall the seals of protected U.S
user data from unauthorized foreign
access
the bottom line is this
American data stored on American soil by
an American company overseen by American
personnel
we call this initiative project Texas
that's why Oracle is headquartered
today U.S Tick Tock data is stored by
default in Oracle service only vetted
Personnel operating in a new company
called Tick Tock U.S data security can
control access to this data now
additionally we have plans for this
company to report to an independent
American board with strong security
credentials